seeing dead people becoming a
neuroscientist and foiling burglars can
be exhausting turns out some child stars
just need a break
anna klumsky won america's hearts when
she starred as veda sultanfuss in the
1991 film my girl only her second
project after a tiny part in 1989's
uncle buck klumsky followed that up with
a less successful but still charming
sequel my girl 2 and similar roles in
trading mom and gold diggers the secret
of bear mountain things started to dry
up for klumsky around 1997 and she
stopped acting entirely in 1998 when she
went to college telling people magazine
in february 2022 as a kid you're just
along for the ride but it can be
extremely damaging in college i had this
out of body moment where i realized i
don't have to do this anymore i don't
have to feel
like this anymore like i don't have to
feel like i won't book something like
i'm not good enough after graduating
from the university of chicago klumsky
told people that she did not immediately
return to acting finding entry-level
journalism jobs but eventually enrolled
in acting school she returned to the
business with a short film in 2005 but
hit it big in 2012 when she scored a
main role in hbo's political comedy veep
klumsky received six primetime emmy
award nominations for playing amy
brookheimer in the show and it remains
the highlight of her career she has
since starred in the netflix miniseries
inventing anna and can most recently be
seen in peacock's original film they
slash them
as far as child stars go mayam bialik
has always seemed to have her head
screwed on straight she began in show
business before she even hit her teens
appearing in tv series like webster and
malloy before becoming super famous as
the titular character in the sitcom
blossom which aired from 1990 to 1995.
despite her success as a kid actor
bialik expressed mixed feelings about
children acting professionally in a post
for her website grok nation bialik
discussed how she sees theater as
valuable for kids but how performing on
cue can take an emotional toll bialik
largely stopped acting for a decade from
1995 to 2005 except for some voice work
and two or three small guest spots in
low profile shows like welcome to
paradox she had a memorable three
episode stint on curb your enthusiasm in
2005 and played a doctor in 10 episodes
of the secret life of the american
teenager but it was bialyx casting as
amy farah fowler in the big bang theory
that completely altered her career she
joined the show in 2010 appeared in more
than 200 episodes and received four
prime time emmy award nominations in
addition to other awards she currently
has her own sitcom call me cat and hosts
jeopardy in her spare time perhaps most
impressively bialik used her time away
from hollywood to earn multiple degrees
including a doctorate in neuroscience
that she completed in 2007 at ucla
when it comes to child actors macaulay
culkin is arguably one of the most
famous there ever was culkin was just
five years old when he made his first
uncredited appearance in a film but
became massively famous at age 10 with
his iconic role as kevin mcallister in
the 1990 film home alone over the next
handful of years he racked up many
credits starring in films such as my
girl the good son and the pagemaster
after appearing as the title character
in the ritchie rich film in 1994 culkin
stepped away from acting for nearly a
full decade culkin retired from acting
in his early teens because he no longer
wanted to do it but also because it
allowed him to stop bankrolling his
parents he became emancipated at age 14
and has said his father was abusive as
he told comedian mark maron on his wtf
podcast in 2018 i had been wanting to
take a break for a while and eventually
i was like i'm done guys hope you all
made your money because there is no more
coming from me
you guys give up or you're thirsty for
more
culkin returned to the screen on his own
terms in
with an acclaimed role in the film party
monster he has since had memorable parts
in movies like saved and in television
series such as american horror story
given how successful mccauley culkin was
as a child many people forget that his
siblings rory and kieran both acted as
children as well kieran in particular
has been able to achieve tremendous
success as an adult after a time away
from the limelight kieran the eldest by
two years began his acting career with a
small part in home alone after which he
worked steadily in films like father of
the bride only the lonely and nowhere to
run he notched more than a dozen screen
credits by the time he turned 18 in 2000
and two years later established himself
with an acclaimed role in igbos down for
which she was nominated a golden globe
award after igb kieran did not appear on
screen for six years though he did have
a few stage roles during that time
telling the hollywood reporter i would
not have been able to handle whatever
kind of success or attention came from
that so i quite literally ran away from
it culkin returned to acting full-time
in 2008 and his career hit new highs in
2018 when he originated the role of
roman roy on the successful hbo show
succession for his work on the series
thus far culkin has been nominated for
one primetime emmy award three golden
globe awards and one individual screen
actors guild award she is nearly 60 now
so younger generations probably do not
know how big of a star brook shields was
back when she was young according to
women's wear daily shields was less than
a year old when she got her start in
modeling and she continued to model
throughout her early life shields was
famously part of a provocative campaign
for calvin klein jeans as a teenager is
the youngest person ever to land on the
cover of vogue and her eyebrows alone
have inspired many a beauty article but
shields is not just known as a model and
her acting career began similarly early
she controversially played a child sex
worker in the 1978 film pretty baby and
as a teen appeared in fair like the blue
lagoon endless love and sahara after
professionally working for literally her
entire life shields took some time off
between 1984 and 1988 to attend
princeton university from which she
graduated with honors according to the
chicago tribune she re-entered hollywood
upon her graduation and in 1996 landed
her biggest role to date the lead in the
sitcom suddenly susan which aired for
four seasons and earned shields two
golden globe award nominations shields
has continued to work steadily in the
years since her sitcom ended appearing
mostly in television in shows like
lipstick jungle and jane the virgin
the list of children who have been
nominated for oscars is short so haley
joel osmond's 2000 academy award nod for
his work in the sixth sense is
significant osmond was 11 years old at
the time of his nomination and he
remains one of the youngest nominees of
all time the actor had already been in
show business for half a decade starting
with commercials and very quickly
transitioning to film one of his first
parts was playing forrest's son in
forest gump and he also had main roles
on the television series thunder alley
and the jeff boxworthy show osmond had
nearly two dozen acting credits before
the sixth since but that's the role that
took him to the next level after his
oscar nom osmund had high profile
leading roles in films such as pay it
forward and ai artificial intelligence
he never officially retired from acting
but osment took on mostly voice work
between the years of 2005 and
2012.
it's cold
it donald give me a coat
though he got into a bit of trouble with
the dui at age 18 osmond got things back
on track and graduated from new york
university during his acting hiatus he
started appearing on camera again in
2013 starting with the television series
alpha house and has established himself
well as an adult thespian with roles in
television series such as future man and
the kaminsky method
andrea barber started her career in 1982
at age six when she began appearing as
carrie brady on the soap opera days of
our lives she remained on days until
1986 during which time she also did
guest stints on other television series
her true claim to fame however is her
scene-stealing role as dj tanner's best
friend and neighbor kimmy gibler on the
iconic sitcom full house barber appeared
in 146 episodes of the show between 1987
and 1995
and then left the entertainment business
as she told e news in 2020 i know a lot
of people who play outlandish characters
like this do struggle with typecasting
or just being seen as that i never
struggled i left the business at 18 just
because my heart wasn't enacting anymore
thankfully for us full house fans
barbara was willing to return to the
role that made her famous when netflix
launched a spin-off fuller house in
2016. the show ran for five seasons but
barber may stick with acting this time
telling e news i've got the bug now i
would love to continue if it's still
doing comedy because i think that's my
sweet spot and i love it so much barber
has since appeared in guest roles on two
series minutia and that girl lele twins
have always been really popular amongst
child actors particularly babies and
toddlers as labor laws limit the amount
of time very young children can spend on
a set along with the olsen twins and the
maori twins the sprouse twins are up
there in terms of fame but while both
dylan and cole sprouse worked as child
actors only cole has come back to acting
full time since they both took a hiatus
to attend college even then he once told
teen vogue that he almost quit for good
the sprouses made their acting debut
before he was even a year old when he
started appearing as patrick kelly in
the sitcom grace under fire he and his
brother shared this role much like they
did with other big gigs like playing
ross's son ben on friends and adam
sandler's adopted son julian in the
comedy big daddy but i did most things
no i did no i did mommy said i did
did he
kids of their generation the sprouse
brothers are perhaps best known as zack
and cody martin the mischievous twin
brothers featured on the disney program
the suite life of zach and cody and it
spin off the suite life on deck cole
sprouse did not act between 2011 and
2017 mostly to attend new york
university and study archaeology he is
now more famous than ever due to his
role as jughead jones on the cw's
riverdale which was recently renewed for
its seventh season
diane lane has been a hollywood
heavyweight for decades the actor
started her screen career in the film a
little romance back in 1979. she had
already been acting in the theater
before that and became a teen star with
roles in films such as ladies and
gentlemen the fabulous stains the
outsiders and rumblefish before deciding
to step away from acting at the age of
19. according to hello magazine lane
moved to georgia during her hiatus from
hollywood while some sources like the
herald have suggested lane retired
because the cotton club was a flop
others have said it had more to do with
rebuilding her relationship with her
mother telling the los angeles times i
hadn't been close to my mom for a long
time so we had a lot of homework to do
we had to repair our relationship
because i wanted my mother back two
years after her 1987 return to acting
she received a prime time emmy
nomination for her work in the
miniseries lonesome dub she has since
been nominated for many awards including
an oscar for her role in the film
unfaithful other standout projects
include a walk on the moon trumbo and
playing superman's earth mom martha kent
in man of steel and batman vs superman
dawn of justice gabby hoffman has lived
an unconventional life the popular child
star grew up in manhattan's chelsea
hotel and according to the guardian she
started acting at age four to help pay
the family's bills her movie debut was
in 1989's field of dreams after which
she starred with hollywood giants in
films like sleepless in seattle and
uncle buck she was also successful as a
teenager with performances in now and
then everyone says i love you and 200
cigarettes hoffman continued appearing
in films until 2001 at which point she
decided to step away from the screen
telling npr i always was planning on
giving it up i never set out to be an
actor i always knew since i was seven or
eight years old that it was a means to
an end and that i wanted to go to
college after attending bard college
hoffman was on the fence about acting
again but eventually decided to try
things out as an adult i saw the maze at
sundance oh yeah and i was like okay
people are making movies like this still
anywhere in the world i want to keep
making movies a decade later she found
major success with a recurring role in
the tv series girls receiving one
primetime emmy nomination and a main
role on amazon's transparent receiving
two nominations hoffman has also done
some amazing work in smaller films such
as obvious child and other high-profile
series like winning time
alicia gorensen is mostly known for
playing the original becky connor on the
sitcom roseanne which she started doing
in 1988 at age 13. she remained with the
show for five seasons eventually leaving
to attend vasser college in addition to
roseanne gorenson appeared in how to
make an american quilt but she was not
as prolific as some other child stars of
her era after leaving roseanne in 1992
goranson appeared on the show a few more
times through 1996 but did not act again
until 1999 telling parade in 2019 i
really miss just having a regular life i
craved being in a real classroom and not
just a studio school room and having the
opportunity to be around my peers
goranson returned to the business with a
juicy role in the heartbreaking film
boys don't cry but disappeared again
until she popped up with a guest spot on
a 2004 episode of sex in the city she
continued to work but mostly in small
guest roles that received little notice
in 2018 goranson returned to prominence
when roseanne was rebooted after the
real life roseanne was fired the show
was renamed the conners in an attempt to
refocus on the rest of the family but
preserve what worked abc has renewed the
connors for season five and goranson's
becky remains a big part of the
spin-offs focus
dora burch is now approaching middle age
but if you remember her as a youngster
you were not alone birch took on her
first film role at the tender age of six
when she appeared in purple people eater
she then went on to film multiple
television shows including day by day
and parenthood but really established
herself as a child star with her film
work her early films include the
halloween classic hocus pocus coming of
age drama now and then and the comedy
monkey trouble she continued acting
throughout her teenage years and
garnered much acclaim with roles in
critical faves like american beauty and
ghost world then the actor somewhat
vanished after acting sporadically
between 2006 and 2017 birch appeared to
have stopped acting entirely from 2012
to 2016. this is not surprising given
that the actor's father was notoriously
heavy-handed according to the new york
times jack burch was allegedly intrusive
on set even after his daughter reached
adulthood he was apparently on set when
his daughter filmed a sex scene in 2007
at age 25 and even got her fired from a
play in 2010 when he threatened one of
her co-stars given her innate talent
birch has thankfully returned to acting
in recent years she dipped her toe back
in with recurring parts on shows like
the walking dead and smaller film roles
like the disaster movie 13 minutes and
has a main role in the upcoming netflix
series wednesday
as the daughter of a famous singer it's
not surprising that actor mackenzie
phillips like her younger half-siblings
bijou and china ended up in the
entertainment business mackenzie's early
start in the industry led to a life
filled with struggle including much
publicized addiction issues and an
incestuous relationship with her own
father which she discussed in her book
high on arrival fortunately phillips
found stability and happiness in her
later years and she is now working as a
counselor for others struggling with
substance addiction i think that people
understand that that i've been there
and that clients believe me when i say
there's a way out phillips began her
acting career in 1973 with a small role
in a tv film doris and a part in the
classic american graffiti she rose to
prominence a couple of years later as
rebellious teenager julie cooper on one
day at a time which remains her most
significant role to date phillips was 25
by the end of the nine season run and
she left acting for music a year later
in 1986. it was not until 1994 that she
returned to the screen mostly for guest
spots on shows like melrose place and
caroline in the city in 1999 phillips
finally found another memorable part
playing a rocker mom in the disney show
so weird she has also had noteworthy
roles on orange is the new black and the
one day at a time reboot series
if you or anyone you know has been a
victim of sexual assault help is
available visit the rape abuse and
incest national network website or
contact reigns national helpline at
1-800-656-hope 1-800-656-4673
[Music]